- If English is your second language,
just getting through that paragraph.
I mean, that is a dense, stupid paragraph.
(slow dramatic music)
- I went to an Ivy League school.
I did great on my SATs.
- I have two degrees
from Stanford University.
I did very well on my standardized tests.
- I graduated from UC Berkeley in 2015.
I'm interested to see
how much harder it is.
- I don't have confidence.
If so many people screwed up.
I'm certainly no better at
language than most of the world.
(dramatic drum music)
- Number 28.
Journeys are the midwives of thought.
- So already, you've got
these abstract concepts,
which is already a tough idea
to wrap your head around.
- Few places are more conducive
to internal conversations
than a moving plane, ship or train.
- There is an almost peculiar correlation
between what is in front of our eyes
and the thoughts we are
able to have in our heads.
- Large thoughts at times
requiring large views,
new thoughts, new places.
Introspective reflections
which are liable to stall
are helped along by the
flow of the landscape.
- The mind blank when thinking
is all it is supposed to do.
The tasks can be as paralyzing
as having to tell a joke
or mimic an accent on demand.
- Thinking improves when parts of the mind
are given other tasks, are
charged with listening to music
or following a line of trees.
- These question are already
three times the length
of questions on the American SAT.
- They are saying, as
contrasted to a journey,
when thinking is all the
mind is supposed to do,
that's like, gonna be something negative.
So I'm looking for
something negative here.
- This is very confusing (laughs).
That sentence, the task can
be as paralyzing as having
to tell a joke or mimic
an accent on demand,
feels like it's from a
totally different passage.
That would throw off so many people.
- I'm going to say it's one.
- I'm going with one.
- I think it should be may be
reluctant to think properly, one.
(ding)
(upbeat music)
- Yes, oh my!
I mean, hey! (laughs)
- I'm making my mom proud!
I'm gonna text her.
- 82 percent, that's worse
than random guessing,
which means this is a
particularly bad question.
- It's a fucked up question.
- Number 26, here we go.
The big question that everyone got wrong.
- So far as you are wholly
concentrated on bringing about
a certain result, clearly the quicker
and easier it is brought about the better.
Uh, what a difficult thing to
have to parse together, okay.
- Your resolve to secure a
sufficiency of food for yourself
and your family will induce
you to spend weary days
in tiling the ground
and tending livestock,
but if nature provided food
and meat in abundance ready
for the table, you would
thank nature for sparing you
much labor and consider
yourself so much better off.
- An executed purpose, in
short, is a transaction
in which the time and energy
spent on the execution
are balanced against the resulting assets,
and the ideal case is
one in which, oh, fudge!
- So the ideal case is one in
which you get a lot of assets
and you don't spend any time on it.
- Purpose, then, justifies
the efforts it exacts
only conditionally, by their fruits.
- Oh my God, this last sentence, ugh!
- Ohh boy!
- This is hard.
- The ideal case is one in which
it doesn't take a lot of time.
That's what I got out of it.
- Okay, I feel like it's number three.
- I'm going number five.
- Five, my final answer.
(ding)
(slow upbeat jazzy music)
- Thank you!
- 90 percent? (laughs)
- That's the first thing
that I checked off,
'cause I was like, it has numbers in it.
I would have never gotten that.
- When I learned Spanish, it
was much easier being like,
the dog ran to the
library, instead of like,
the thing about language theory is.
I would never be able to understand
that in a foreign language.
- If you're talking
about suicidal thoughts,
that takes school pressure
to whole new degree.
- In Korea, where you go to college,
that's your whole life goal.
- They're set up to fail.
Look at these questions
(laughs), these aren't like,
you're never gonna have to talk like this.
It's so highly specialized.
It doesn't need to be a
general standardized tests.
- I hope that students can start to see
academic success isn't the
only validator of who you are.
I have so much respect.
My heart really goes out to you.
(soft slow music)